run cities seeing a violent summer crime
wave viewer warning the video is tough
to look at a scooter riding Maniac going
on a deadly Rampage here in New York
randomly shooting at people from his
moped he wounded three and took the life
of an 87 year old father of six who was
heading out to pray
the crazed gunman smirking after being
arrested police sources telling NBC that
the man appears to have mental issues
okay and there's more Devastation a
former Afghan interpreter who risked his
life for American troops in Warzone was
shot and killed in Washington D.C while
he was picking up an extra shift as a
lift driver
he leaves behind a wife and four kids
police are still looking for suspects
who were caught fleeing in this chilling
surveillance footage watch
I'm sure he was not reaching uh Judge
Jeanine uh that's just the saddest story
of all time all of these stories are sad
we just don't know the stories if you
peel them all back there's a story of
someone who didn't deserve it didn't ask
for it and all of a sudden they're dead
in their family's lives are thrown into
turmoil until the day they die and
that's the problem you know there's
nothing new that I can say here there's
nothing new if there are no consequences
Behavior will not change and you know
the the the the quality of of people's
lives is meaningless now if someone dies
it's like it's no big deal and it's it's
these damns who believe in this elusive
undefinable social justice I don't think
they even know what they're going for
and we this will lead to the destruction
of our society because the more people
are afraid the more they're not going to
go outside their kids aren't going to go
outside and it it is it is the loss of
our freedom it leads to losing
everything I mean it's a decline of a
civilization and it's stoppable it's
just stoppable and all this stuff about
bail is unconstitutional these people
are idiots it's in the Eighth Amendment
to the Constitution It Was Written in
it's not as though the founding fathers
didn't say you know what Baal uh isn't
appropriate they said bail is
appropriate under certain situations are
all situations depending upon whether or
not it's undue how about sources saying
that they believe the the moped Shooter
had mental issues Harold probably
probably did I agree with the judge on
this we've talked about this a lot we
need more police officers on the street
we need to pay police officers more uh
we need longer punishment for people who
commit crimes we also need to have
background checks uh for guns we need to
track ghost guns and we need to probably
build more jails because we find
ourselves in a position that if we if we
don't don't in Cash's bill which I'm an
advocate for and a proponent for and
have said over and over again we're
going to continue to have some of the
outcomes that the judge that the judge
mentions but we seem to have a body
politic that defies some of the polling
and some of the Common Sense things
ninety percent of Americans believe we
should do something about guns and the
body politic the power around uh 10 20
of the thinking here says that we just
won't I would love a compromise more
jails more cops less guns if I were in
Congress if I were in the Senate as a
Democrat I'd be trying to find
Republicans that wanted to do this from
the states where you may have uh these
kind of awful crime rates these kind of
awful stories and outcomes this is what
Congress and this is what State
legislatures Should be doing it feels
like we've been covering stories like
this every single day for the last
couple years for a few years leading up
to it and we knew this because of a lot
of the prosecutors that got hired and
went away it went all across the country
so just another point on the Afghan who
came to America so first of all he was
10 years old when he raised his hand at
our base in Afghanistan and said I'd
like to help he taught himself English
he worked for us for eight years I
believe it was eight years and he saved
the lives of several of our people and
then we break our promise we can't get
him here but they finally get him out
they get him to Abu Dhabi where his wife
has a baby in a refugee camp they get
here guess where they went went to
Philadelphia he's working in
Philadelphia and he's like wait this
place is too unsafe let me move my
family to a place that might be better
he chose Washington DC and unfortunately
that's because you have the same type of
criminal punishment which is lacks you
ended up with this situation you know
that those young boys that are running
that they've probably had been picked up
before but they've probably not had any
consequences so that's how you get fewer
guns on the street and that's how you
get fewer crimes as you have more
consequences but every time I think
about these senseless killings
especially in Washington D.C think about
how President Biden saved so many
Democrats 173 house Democrats voted to
support DC's crime Bill where they
wanted to water it down and they thought
Biden had his back and remember the
Democrats were so mad because Biden was
like well maybe we shouldn't go that far
they should be thanking him today for
saving them from that Greg Gutfeld well
you know the the Afghan guy obviously is
ill is unlucky he came at a time when
America is that it's I think it's at its
worst my question is how long does this
last because we keep saying this we keep
talking about this and it seems to not
get any better so this the scooter
shooter was known around the
neighborhood as being a troublemaker
which meant that he his actions you know
harmed the quality of public life
already and yet that wasn't stopped
right that the police weren't arresting
him he was riding on sidewalks this is
what people do now in in New York city
so these this is a behavior that harms
the quality of life that because there
are no consequences expands into more
dangerous and high-risk Behavior so now
he's shooting people from a bike the
more the crimes are more flagrant
because of the reductions in punishment
which affects human behavior we're
rewiring the brain this is what I'm
trying to figure out if this is long
term or not we're rewiring the brain not
to expect consequences so we're creating
kind of amoral individuals like the guy
on the bike like that person didn't
exist before that's somebody that thinks
that I've gotten away with this I've
gotten away with this I've gotten this
is my brain is telling me that there are
no consequences for the decisions that I
make so the lawlessness continues it's
like it's like the broken windows Theory
but it's way worse because it's about
changing your brain and that's what
scares me is I feel like I'm seeing
different people out there these are not
normal criminals these are completely
amoral Brazen I would say we're
aggressive going and we're literally
turning back the clock this is like
people riding around
going on horses with revolvers yeah all
right crazy I wanna Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great comment Terry any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on Fox you can get it all here
on YouTube so subscribe right now